ou alors dans les boîtes on se rencontre
on rencontre des gens qu'on rencontre
pas dans la même journée est un jour ttf
si la hausse à long et à rodez ac est
arrivé alors rodage sais pas si vous
savez qui c'est le sait quand même vous
avez fait vite album ensemble
d'entrepôts je suis sûrement et puis
alors après on a lu dans la presse des
choses que tu as dit qu'ils étaient pas
très gentil quand même ça faisait un peu
les nôtres les sages appelée l'année
macartney antique quoi je lis cet ajout
du oui à c'était un peu ça quand même
farinas s'était très méchant jamais ça
jamais fait ça ça veut dire ça oui
ouais non et alors il y avait un côté
quand même quand vous êtes retrouvé j'ai
trouvé ça formidable parce qu'on a tous
écouté vos disques et tout et j'ai dit
faut les réunir à la télé alors
j'aimerais y mélange bien sous tous les
est officiellement mort je le vois mes
options on s'est croisé un soir en plus
tard même mis au défi le rayon toujours
pas que les gens soient étonnés
je donne un auteur et un composteur se
disent beaucoup de choses par chansons
interposées
c'est un relation passionnelle et il est
normal que quand il ya un arrêt
provisoire ou définitif dans leurs
valeurs ammann dans la rame ou rebond
s'accommodera ça ne se passe pas comme
ça bonjour bonsoir on arrête un break
ensemble en plus etienne a dit des
choses ans après c'est vrai c'est la
liberté du funding de bistrot mais tuer
le père tout ça ce n'est pas peut-être
pas trop d'aléas dit beaucoup de choses
et comme dans les paroles de chansons il
y avait des choses bien et des choses
moins bien des des choses réussies et
des choses par ici moi j'ai rarement ou
jamais répondu parce que moi je suis
musicien et que ce n'est pas mon rôle
écrit des paroles une des choses qui l'a
dit une fois parce que à chaque fois
quand les choses étaient belles pourquoi
je souhaitais pas bay paraît prendre des
cachets t by effaré pour non plus parce
que je lui pardonnais tout parce que
c'était joli parmi les choses je vis qui
les vip et avait dit qu'il a arrêté
d'écrire pour moi parce qu'il ne tenait
pas faire le sac des petites filles
ouais pense que me laisser là où je
voulais en égalité devant partout la
balle au centre
non non non vous
ce n'était pas beau elle joue août avait
dit ça dans le journal avait lu des
trucs quand même assez dur c'était le
dit c'est lui qui le dit à un journal
qui chassera les relations passionnelles
tout ça c'est pas grave ce qui est
important c'est que il ya des chansons
qui est tant mieux si elle reste dans le
coeur des gens ils un jour de faire
travailler tous les êtres maintenant
maintenant qu'on fait tourner de tahiti
faisons pas nous sommes la petite fille